هل فهمتم شيئا مما قال؟
وأنا أيضا لم أفهم أي شيء
، لكن وبلا شك فإن هناك كارثة عالمية قادمة!!!
أمريكا تهدد الصين ، وبكين تراوغ
لكن هل تستطيع أمريكا إخافة الصين؟ ...
رئيس الشيشان يرسل أقوى جنرالاته
بقيادة ألف مقاتل، إلى أوكرانيا...
الصين تغلق أكبر مدنها وتبني المستشفيات
وتعلن حالة الطوارئ عقب انتشار هذا الفيروس!!،،
...روسيا تظهر أسلحة جديدة منها
راجمات صواريخ مرعبة وأسلحة تفوق
سرعة الصوت في أوكرانيا فكيف ستستطيع
كييف الصمود أكثر؟ ...
وبين هذا وذاك الوساطات جارية والمفاوضات
لا تتوقف، وموسكو تضع يداً في المفاوضات
ويداً تُسقط المناطق على الأرض
وتُحكم السيطرة، مع وجود بشارات
باقتراب الطرفين من حل خلال المفاوضات،
لكن هل تخضع أوكرانيا لشروط وطلبات روسيا؟
مهلا فموسكو تتهم أمريكا مجددا بإفساد
المفاوضات!!،...بين روسيا وأمريكا
تتجدد الاتهامات باستخدام الأسلحة البيولوجية
فأيهما يستخدمه يا ترى؟
مكالمة لساعتين بين بايدن ونظيره الصيني
من التداعيات والعواقب التي ستواجهها الصين
في حال قدمت دعمًا ماديًا لروسيا
وهي تقوم بهجمات عنيفة على المدن
الأوكرانية والمدنيين”.
وقال الرئيس الصيني، شي جين بينغ في اتصال
هاتفي مع بايدن: "العلاقات بين الدول
لا يجب أن تصل إلى مرحلة المواجهة،
الحرب والصدام لا يخدمان مصلحة أحد،
السلام والأمن الكنزان الرئيسان للمجتمع الدولي"
"الأزمة الأوكرانية أمر لا نريد رؤيته"
أمر رمضان قديروف بإرسال ألف مقاتل
باتجاه العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف،
للمساعدة في العمليات العسكرية لروسيا هناك،
بقيادة أحد أقوى الجنرالات الشيشانية أبتي أرناوفيتش،
وهو مساعد رئيس الشيشان في الشؤون الدفاعية،،
وقال قديروف أن أبتي أرناوفيتش مقاتل
متمرس وقادر على اتخاذ القرارات المناسبة
في الأوقات الصعبة والقاسية،
وسينفذ مهمته على أكمل وجه..
( أوميكرون يرعب العالم)
أعلنت وزارة الصحة الصينية تفشي الفيروس
في البلاد،، وتسجيلها أعلى حالات وفاة
منذ بدء الوباء، وهناك أغلقت السلطات مدنا بأكملها
يسكنها الملايين، وتم إلغاء الرحلات الجوية..
وبناء مستشفيات مؤقتة لاحتواء الحالات،
ومنظمة الصحة العالمية تحذر من انتشار الوباء مجددا،
حيث تجاوزت الحالات الجدية ١١مليون إصابة
مع ٤٠ألف حالة وفاة.....
...لم يعد بوسع العالم تحمل المزيد
يا أصحاب العيون الضيقة!!،،
(الأسلحة المرعبة!!)
قالت روسيا  إنها استخدمت الصواريخ
كينجال (الخنجر) التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعة الصوت في تدمير مستودع أسلحة كبير
بمنطقة إيفانو فرانكيفسك في شرق أوكرانيا.
وذكرت وكالة إنترفاكس للأنباء أن هذه هي المرة
الأولى التي تنشر فيها روسيا منظومة كينجال
الأسرع من الصوت منذ الدفع بقواتها إلى أوكرانيا .
أول ظهور لراجمة صواريخ
خلال الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية،
راجمة الصواريخ بي إم 30 سميرتش،
التي صنعت في العهد السوفيتي،
مزودة ب١٢ أنبوب إطلاق للصواريخ،
ويستخدم فيها ذخائر عنقودية متنوعة،،
لكن ماذا عن راجمة الصواريخ التي تدعى
بالأرض المحروقة أو الشمس الحارقة
هل دخلت طور الاستخدام في الحرب على أوكرانيا؟
(بصيص الأمل)
أعلن مفاوض روسي، في المحاثات مع أوكرانيا،
"أن موسكو اقتربت من التوافق مع أوكرانيا
بشأن وضعها المحايد، وعدم انضمامها
إلى حلف الناتو، ونزع سلاحها"،
بحسب وكالة "رويترز".
وأشار إلى "اننا نبحث بنودًا تتعلق بالضمانات
الأمنية لأوكرانيا، في حال تخليها عن الانضمام للناتو".
وكان وزير الخارجية الأوكراني، ديمترو كوليبا
قد أشار، إلى أنه بحث مع نظيره التركي
جاويش أوغلو، التركيز على الإعداد لاجتماع
بين الرئيس الأوكراني، فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
والرئيس الروسي، فلاديمير بوتين.
لكن موسكو  عادت واتهمت  واشنطن
بمنع وفد كييف المفاوض من الموافقة على
أبسط شروطها، فهل تقف المفاوضات عند ذلك؟
(موعد غزو تايوان)
نيوزويك عن وثيقة مخابراتية روسية:
الصين لديها خطط لغزو تايوان الخريف المقبل،
وكان قد أشار المتحدث باسم وزارة الدفاع الصينية،
وو تشيان، إلى أنه "سنبذل قصارى جهدنا
لإعادة التوحيد السلمي
الا انه  نبذل قصار جهدنا لإعادة  لضفتي
مضيق تايوان، وملتزمون بشدة بهذا التوحيد
على أساس مبدأ: دولة واحدة ونظامان"،
وأكد تشيان أن "قضية تايوان شأن داخلي
خاص بالصين، والتدخل الأجنبي أمر غير مقبول
"، مردفاً: "كلما ارتفع ضجيج الولايات المتحدة
واليابان بشأن قضية تايوان، كلما عملنا بقوة
أكبر لحماية السيادة الوطنية وسلامة الأراضي".
(الأحداث والتطورات)
قديروف العمليات لا تسير كما خططنا
ومقاتلونا لا يتسرعون في عملياتهم
من أجل سلامة المدنيين، ويتم تطهير
ماريوبول بيتا بيتا حتى لا يتضرر المدنيون،
قالت وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية إنها فقدت الوصول
إلى بحر آزوف مؤقتا وذلك بعد إحكام القوات
الروسية على ميناء ماريوبول الرئيسي على البحر
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تنشر صورا لتدمير
٦ مسيرات أوكرانية بينها واحدة
من طراز بيرقدار التركية ..
كما نشرت الوزارة الروسية أيضا
مقاطع فيديو تظهر المروحيات الروسية
وهي تدمر منظومات دفاع جوية في
أحد المطارات العسكرية الأوكرانية.
المروحيات دمرت أيضا المدرعات
وكل ما وجدته من أسلحة أوكرانية وأجرت إنزالاً
عسكرياً في المطار...
قالت وزارة الدفاع الروسية أن، قواتها دمرت
أيضا مراكز للاتصالات اللاسلكية والاستطلاع
بالقرب من مدينة أوديسا الساحلية باستخدام
النظام الصاروخي الساحلي الروسي (الحصن).
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن يعلن عن إرسال بلاده
شحنة أسلحة غير مسبوقة وهي في طريقها
إلى أوكرانيا وتحتوي هذه الشحنة على صواريخ
مضادة للطائرات وذخائر كما أنها تحتوي
على طائرات مسيرة بدون طيار متطورة
تصيب أهدافها بدقة،، بحسب ما قاله البيت الأبيض
الجيش الروسي يعلن، أنه تمكن من دخول "ماريوبول"
وستشكل السيطرة على ماريوبول،
منعطفاً مهماً في الحرب وستُمكن روسيا
من تأمين تواصل جغرافي بين قواتها الآتية
من شبه جزيرة القرم (جنوب)
وقوات منطقة دونباس (شرق).
الآلاف من الروس يحتفلون بذكرى ضم جزيرة القرم.
في مكالمة هاتفية: ماكرون يعرب عن قلقه
بشأن مصير مدينة ماريوبول وبوتين
يتهم أوكرانيا بارتكابها "جرائم حرب"
وأشار بوتين إلى "الهجمات الصاروخية
والمدفعية واسعة النطاق على بلدات دونباس"
في شرق أوكرانيا الناطق بالروسية الذي يسيطر
عليه جزئيا انفصاليون موالون لروسيا.
وأكد الرئيس الروسي أن "القوات المسلحة الروسية
تبذل قصارى جهدها للحفاظ على أرواح المدنيين،
لا سيما من خلال إقامة ممرات إنسانية لإجلائهم بأمان".
اتهامات وسجال بين مندوبي روسيا وأمريكا
في مجلس الأمن في جلسته الطارئة لمناقشة
تطورات الأوضاع في أوكرانيا،،
واتهم مندوب روسيا أمريكا بأنها كانت تجهز
معامل بيولوجية في أوكرانيا لتستخدمها ضد روسيا
مؤكدا حصولهم على أدلة خلال الغزو الحالي
لأوكرانيا، بينما اتهمت مندوبة أمريكا روسيا
بأنها تخطط لاستخدام أسلحة كيماوية وبيولوجية
في أوكرانيا..
....
السلاح البيولوجي هو أحد أسلحة الدمار الشامل،
وهو سلاح متعارف عليه منذ القدم،
قديما كان يتم تسميم الأنهار والآبار،،
أما اليوم هناك العديد من الطرق وإحدى الطرق
هي الطيور التي اتهمت موسكو واشنطن
أنها تعمل على تجهيزها بأمراض خبيثة
في أوكرانيا لتطلقها على روسيا...
علاقة متميزة بين الرئيسين السابقين
لأمريكا وروسيا كلينتون  ويلتسن،،
يقابله علاقة شائكة بين الرئيسين الحاليين
للدولتين بوتين وبايدن،، فهل هي مجرد معركة
خاطفة ثم يعود البلدان للاتفاق فيما بينهما
ويخسر الداخلون على الخط. دعونا نرى
في المستقبل ما الذي سيحدث؟